Hi everybody and welcome. Today we're
going to be looking at uh it's a
workshop all about what relationship is
there between Google's knowledge graph
and Google's push features such as
discover and big moments and there is a
lot to learn today and we're going to
learn it today with Andrea Vulpini from
WordLift, CindyRum from Mobile Moxy and
Don Anderson from Bertie. all three
incredible experts in the realms of SEO,
data, knowledge, graphs, and generally
how Google's figuring out from strings
to things. So, can we start with you,
Andy? Introduce yourself and Wordlift,
please.
>> Hello. So, um I'm a CEO and co-founder
of WordLift and uh we build knowledge
graphs to automate SEO and I'm very
excited for today's session.
>> Brilliant. Cindy, your turn.
Sorry, I was muted. Can you hear me?
>> Yep, we can.
>> Okay. Um, the So, I'm CindyRum, uh, CEO
of Mobile Moxy, and we specialize in
mobile SEO and cutting edge SEO, and
I've over the years developed a
reputation for being good at predicting
uh, what Google's going to do next.
>> Brilliant stuff. And Dor from Bertie.
>> Yeah. Hi, everybody. I'm Don Anderson
from Bertie. I'm also an SEO and yeah,
I've not got too much well following
those two introductions. Nothing too
exciting other than I'm a nosy crow SEO
that loves digging into information
retrieval, academic papers, but with a
view to trying to think how I can help
clients by applying those things that I
read about. So, yeah, like everybody
here, just fascinated with search and
the direction it's headed in.
>> Brilliant. That's a great introduction.
I'm by the way Jason Barard from Cali
Cube. Uh I'm specializing in brand
search which is what appears when your
audience Googles your brand name or your
personal name or an entity name of any
type. And I specialize in helping my
clients to optimize what appears
optimize their brand SER and manage the
knowledge panel which is the part on the
right hand side. Um manage what's in
there manage the information make sure
it's truthful make sure it's positive
accurate and convincing. And I love it.
I absolutely love it and this is my
little niche and contrary to a lot of
people in the SEO community, I try to
avoid thinking too much about the core
algorithm that Google has and I focus
just on my little corner of the uh the
world. So, um welcome to everybody.
Thank you so much connected connective
connected data excuse me for having us.
And today we're going to try to look at
search and present to you guys and gals
if I may say all of how Google is using
the knowledge graph and data to drive
search, how it's doing it today, how
it's going to do it in the future, and
especially those push features that
we're seeing more and more discover big
moments and so on so forth because we're
so used to seeing Google uh doing pull,
which is when somebody searches, they
give them some solutions, some possible
solutions. And here we're looking at
Google increasingly going into push. Uh
Andy, I know you've got a lot to say
about that.
Um yeah, I mean um I'm I'm very
interested in in this uh transition from
from push to from pull to push and um
and I think that we're seeing u changes
constantly happening at um you know in
the different Google products that um
are also shaping different uh type of
traffic and um I think that um one one
good hypothesis to to prove is that uh
when when moving from from from pull to
push, Google is trying to create
a different type of traffic that it's
more similar to the traffic that we see
on social network. And that's that's
what I can see from from a direct
experience. But I'm very um curious to
know if uh if if Don and Cindy see it in
the same way and then I think we can
kind of uh dive deep into our experience
and try to understand if it is it true
that when we move from from pull to push
the traffic changes and the behavior of
the users are also changing.
>> Brilliant. Yeah. Cindy, what what what
are your thoughts on that from the the
move from pull to push? Well, it's an
interesting way to kind of structure the
thought process because we all know that
Google has tried many times to create a
separate social network um and failed
miserably every single time. And so
perhaps what Andy is seeing is Google
not trying to create a social network
but become a social network. Um or at
least uh have the the kind of addictive
or uh repeat um engagement that is not
just from wanting to do a search but
wanting to connect um in other ways with
information or people or what have you.
Um and I think it it would be it's not a
horrible idea. It's a good business
model for lots of companies and if um
but and also I think Google is
threatened by some of the big social
networks. They feel uh these social
networks encroaching on on space that
they want. Um so yeah I I agree. I think
that does seem right now at least to be
a direction that they want to go.
>> Brilliant.
>> Um well I have a totally different view.
my view based on u I think it was in
Paris when I attended uh which one was
it SIGR which is an information
retrieval conference and they they
always at the beginning of any big
conferences like that and they show what
papers have been accepted and they show
off the word cloud of the most popular
topics that have been accepted as papers
and recommendation recommener was the
word that was massive. So there there
seems to have like been over the years
in IR there was this whole debate about
whether recommending was also
information retrieval. Yeah. So the
likes of Spotify, Netflix etc. where
actually the user doesn't have to go and
search because based on what they've
logged on before recommendations are
made. So for me Google isn't just it's
not really anything to do with the
social aspect for me. It's more to do
with the fact that it's it's learning
all the time about what people want this
person search for this so they also want
this particularly with like questions
feeding in and more and more machine
learning. So it's it's suggestion and it
is I know we're going to come to it
eventually but it's all part of the task
driven search part of things you know
because tasks are are a long journey you
know the many many microtasks ultimately
you know meet an ultimate goal type
thing. So uh for me it's more about
transitioning into a combination of
recommener and also when people have
explicit searches.
So it's it's separate for me to social
media. That's my view.
>> Don, do you think they have to be
mutually exclusive like this idea of
recommener versus social? Because I
think that that's part of the value that
that Google's going to get is like um
similar audiences or you know I'm
friends with you and so I might like
similar things to you. I mean to me I
think they fit nicely.
I think well you know that there's the
whole thing with the flock the federated
privacy thing where actually they are
almost combining interests if you like
where they hide the individual in the
interests of a crowd yeah using I think
it's dot product matrix factorization
ultimately you know the same as Spotify
this person likes this so there's a high
probability that because this person
likes this this other person also likes
this so there is a social aspect where
they take almost like anonymized cohort.
So it's cohort analysis rather than
individuals because of the whole privacy
thing. Yeah. So there is a definitely a
social aspect because social networks
are just crawable six degrees of
separation that kind of thing. So it's
definitely gonna cross over and as you
said it's not mutually exclusive at all.
It's just more of a I think the
experience will become like an
omnipresent experience like social is
all around us. So yes, two they're
together but I don't think they're I
don't think the focus is to become a
social network. It's to
>> No, not at all. Totally agree with that.
>> Totally agree that. Yeah, that's um
>> it's about the experience of it being
all around us type thing.
>> I I'll agree with that as well because
Google's tried to be an like an explicit
social network and it's never worked.
But they can have a social networking
aspect uh for their learning algorithms
and their recommending algorithms that
that isn't the core focus of
>> and also the social aspect in the
presentation on the SER which would be
cameos for example that Andrea's
terribly into
I mean for you Andrea is the cameo
aspect social
>> cameo is a good experiment of of like
these this idea of um you know bringing
uh individual features into into Google
SER and so so it goes into this
direction. I totally agree that if you
look at from the technology point of
view it's it's you know moving from from
information retrieval to content
recommendation but then if you look at
from you know the business perspective
it's it's about uh creating a new stream
of traffic which it's more similar to to
what we see on social network. Now
cameos we don't know if it's going to
last but but it's pretty impressive
because u I still have it running on on
my personal SER and it kind of give you
the idea of how search is going to
change and it's going to become more
personalized than than than you know
just an information retrieval system. So
that's that's one aspect. Then there is
another aspect that um I I I feel um can
be anticipated is that um as as we are
looking at um content it's it's it's
Google is is striving to combine
different media types and we see a lot
with uh you know the the impact of of
videos on on SER or you know rich media
of all sorts the key moments uh video
segmentation
there is um new features that are
combining the different modality uh and
that's that's another pivotal change
that it's happening and it's also
enabling a different level of
interaction and and chameos is one of
these thing where you actually are
presented with questions that Google is
probably gathering by looking at
searches done on on your personal brand
but then it's translating these into you
know original video content that you are
producing for answering these questions.
So, you know, multiple senses are kind
of coming together into into the new
search experience.
>> This is a huge thing that's not getting
a lot of attention. So, I'm glad you're
bringing it up. Um because I feel like
um you know my focus has been mobile for
a long time and I feel like the phone is
gonna be the glue that makes this
multimodal experience possible. Um
because if you think about things like
um uh image search uh where you submit a
photo directly from your camera um or
translation where you submit a photo of
text and it translates but also the
ability to cast um to cast video but
also cast audio. So the idea of the
cameos is kind of like Google wants to
fill its cache of um important people
answering questions so that they have
enough data to launch a video version of
a people also ask
um and so that I can ask of my Google
assistant um a question about you Andy
and you'll pop up and start answering
that question. It's pretty it's pretty
scary when you do it with me because I
only have this very boring business
related question that you can ask me on
Caminos. But yeah. Yeah, I totally agree
with you. I mean it's it's it's about
creating an index that it's it's
multimodel but it's kind of you know
taking taking the experience to to a
different level than just you know
making a query running a query and
inspecting a result.
that I think this is multimodality or
what I've been called multiaceted
companies are going to be I think it's
going to be a new signal of trust to
replace links real companies have
multiple modalities that they
communicate in they'll have videos
they'll have podcasts you know the more
modalities that you have the more real
you might be perhaps if I were Google
looking to replace links as a primary
signal for trust that's where I would
headed.
>> That's interesting. Jason, I think you
have a lot of data about these. Can you
share some of your data about, you know,
how powerful a brand is when it kicks
in, you know, different modalities on on
on its own branded SER?
>> Well, I mean, yeah, I thanks. So I I
focus on on branded searches as I said
and for Cali cube we've been doing
experiment for the last nine months and
basically Cindy doing what you're
suggesting is creating whereas we didn't
have much video content before creating
a vast amount of video content very
quickly uh we publish an hour video
every week and at least two one minute
videos to two-minute videos every single
day with very simple answers to simple
questions or simple explanations of
something that I found interesting. And
what's been happening is we've seen a
few things. Number one is the brand very
quickly gets the video boxes. So you see
the videos when you search our brand
name Twitter as well because we're
pushing it out on Twitter. Um and the
other thing is that we're seeing uh that
we're dominating more and more our own
video space and the content space around
it because we're also doing transcripts
and subtitles to help Google along with
its understanding of what we're doing in
the videos. And we've seen an incredible
increase in the number of associated
entities in related searches. For
example, wordlift now pops up when you
search for caddy cube, which means caddy
cube and wordlift. Google can see the
relationship between the two companies.
But also the topics that we deal with,
knowledge graph and so on and so forth.
And I was looking at SE ranking and our
ranking for Google's knowledge graph. We
rank I think 12th. And by those
traditional signals you were talking
about, we've got zero in links.
Uh we're the 3 millionth biggest site in
the world which is quite pathetic and
our domain authority as measured by
whoever they get their data from is 12
or something silly like that and all of
the ones around us are people like AHS
Seamrush
Yoast all of these big hitters who are
big sites who and Google themselves of
course and the only other exception in
that list is is Kare Gabur from Holistic
SEO who who's who's got a similar
strategy to hours, which is a lot of
great content built around entities. And
it seems to me that by you that he's
doing the entities better than we are.
We're doing the the video content better
than he is, as it were. But we're both
hitting well above our weight. And I
find that incredibly exciting.
>> Or what I call cutting in line. This is
the SEO strategy of the day. And the
people who are still uh toiling and
working hard to get really crappy links
uh one at a time um might be Oh, Don
disagrees. I saw uh you're muted. You're
muted.
>> Don, you're muted. Mute yourself. We
want to hear.
>> Seriously, I I've I've never approached
I've never been one for going down the
whole like get more links, rank higher.
I think a ridiculously outdated strategy
in today's modern search and I've I've
always been around, you know, building
relevance clusters, um,
>> co-occurrence,
>> navigate navigable small world graphs,
that kind of thing. And I think that
that's kind of the sort of thing that
you've built there, Jason. Almost like a
very related
hierarchical navigable small world graph
that actually is very niche. Yeah. And
be very strong and very clear. So, of
course, it's more relevant than somebody
who's bigger. You know, the size really
doesn't matter when it comes to
relevance, does it? You know,
>> no. And and what's really interesting is
that Google's seeing it, which is
something kind of maybe we had a doubt
about. And I've actually got a client
who works with Wordlift as well. And we
did a similar thing, which is why I'm
now doing it for myself because you do
it for your client and you think, "Oh,
that's great. I'll do it for myself."
And we focused on eims, which is very um
niche as well. And we once again did no
back links at all and we're now
outranking Apple for what is an ESIM?
And that's taken us two years. But all
we've done is created an incredible
series of simple answers to simple
questions around an incredibly core
topic. And we haven't varied. We haven't
moved outside our core topics and we
identified the entities using WordLift.
I mean bit of bit of a push there for
Wordlift. But Andy, I mean from your
perspective, you're seeing a lot of
this.
Yeah, I'm I'm starting to look again at
links. I always [laughter]
maybe there's value there. I don't know.
I mean, I I'm starting to question all
of these, but uh no uh yeah, I mean
entity based uh SEO, I think what what
what we we we all do. I mean, from from
Cindy to Dawn to Jason, I mean, we all
been working on this entity based SEO. I
don't know if it it's a correct way of
of of of saying it, but I think it does
make sense when you look at from the
side of a of a machine that needs to
understand things rather than than
crawling. the crawling aspect is still
uh you know driven by links
>> and that's that's one one thing that uh
I I I I realized lately and kind of uh
helped me change slightly the
perspective on hey maybe some links are
helpful [snorts] because uh
>> I was going to sorry can I just chip in
with something really really
>> relevant there I thought that yeah and
and yeah there is that whole like bread
first crawling versus depth first
crawling so important and obviously the
higher up towards a route you are then
and that's driven by links and the link
graph and the nodes etc. But
interestingly enough, I actually saw
something on Bing's website that talked
about crawling the other day and it
actually said if you have a knowledge
graph or it might have been actually
Google's it said if you have a know if
you have structured data on your web
pages it's better it's easier for us to
crawl it. When I looked a lot just
recently a lot of the time they talk
about crawling through knowledge graphs.
Yeah. So actually it kind of feel like
it's tipping slightly towards crawling
via knowledge graph extraction and away
maybe from trusting just links. Yeah.
And links are just one of very many
things as we know. So
>> but with with if it's oh sorry Cindy can
I just make a point then I'll pass it on
to you with ID if they're crawling a
knowledge graph and you've got an
internal knowledge graph that you've
built up you don't need the link to the
page you just need the link to your site
and once it gets in there it crawls
around your knowledge graph. Would that
make sense?
>> Well, yeah. I mean, it was just I was
just I spotted it and I thought, "Oh my
god, that's super interesting." It was
actually on either Google or Bing's page
about how crawl about crawl. It was
about crawl optimization. And it
actually said add a knowledge graph or
add structured data. Yeah. And I
thought, right, what well that literally
is saying you're going to get better
crawl if you've got better structured
data on there, which
>> and it makes sense.
>> Yeah. I mean, it does particularly when
there's a lot of papers that are talking
now about crawling through knowledge
graphs. Yeah.
>> Right. So, I cut you off. Sorry.
>> Yeah. So, so
>> maybe,
>> so Don, maybe maybe I'm misunderstanding
what you're saying or at least taking a
different spin on it, but when you when
you say it, the way you said it, it
makes me think of this idea that I've
talked about before, which is that the
knowledge graph is much bigger than what
we're actually presented. That Google's
knowledge graph is very deep and has
layers of information that tie together
all of their different platforms. um
that are not necessarily always visually
um presented in a a knowledge panel
result. So for instance, Google has
loads of information that they get from
Google Play about videos and music and
books um and artists and stuff like
that. Um and I've always thought of that
as one way to be to get from this place
in Google to the knowledge graph. And
similarly, you know, Google my business
is its own section of the knowledge
graph. Um, and so I just I like to
remind people that when Google talks
about or when a search engine talks
about crawling the knowledge graph,
there are explicit HTML links and then
there are links in the knowledge graph
that don't have an ahref. They're just
associations, right? And so I think that
needs to be spelled out potentially for
some of our listeners.
>> Yeah, that's really interesting. I've
been talking about this, but talking
about knowledge graph verticals like
podcasts, Google books, Google Scholars,
Google My Business, and Google Play,
which you've just put into my little
brain now. Um, and and that idea that
they have all these verticals, and what
I'm seeing is that they have trouble
communicating horizontally as a rule.
They all trigger knowledge panels, but
they don't necessarily communicate
horizontally. Google's NLP is one way
they appear to be able to bring them
together. and Bill Swazki was suggesting
that they've got I think he called it a
thesaurus that references all of these
IDs. They're all KGM IDs and that we're
seeing at KQ but I don't have enough
data to actually make a real statement
that a lot of them are being moved into
the main knowledge graph as and when you
can basically convince Google or or or
educate Google let's say to the fact
that it is an entity with these proper
relationships. And one of the problems
we've seen is for example authors moving
from Google books into the main
knowledge graph lose their books in the
knowledge panel because the books even
if they get moved across don't get moved
across with their relationships intact
and that's going to be one of the big
tricks for us. Sorry, excuse I was going
to say it's lack of consistency the way
that different data banks if you like or
verticals are you know I mean obviously
we're we're on a connected data
conference so all the audience will know
about the different way in which
knowledge graphs and schema and lots of
different markups have been proposed
over the years and there there's lots of
inconsistency everywhere. So um
databases are like that you know they
they're not all defined exactly the same
are they? And ultimately knowledge
graphs are just databases and every
website dri that's driven by data is a
database and you know there's all these
different databases trying to talk to
each other but without if you like the
same headers to to mean the same things.
So it's inconsistency that that causes a
lot of these problems. I I I spoke a few
years ago at a conference and shared the
Michelangelo in the knowledge graph was
be had a picture of the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle and that's because the data
for one part was coming from somewhere
to the different to the actual text if
you like and and that's what it is. It's
just inconsistency and lack of
confidence.
>> Yeah. And confidence is incredibly
important. I think people forget and
they they think understanding is enough.
If you get a knowledge panel, Google's
understood. That knowledge panel in my
terminology is flaky as soon as Google
isn't confident. And you can lose it as
soon as you get that inconsistency you
mentioned, Cindy. And that's a big
danger with Google is it's like this
child where you've taught it something.
You think, right, okay, it's understood.
This child is understood. And then if
you can get grandma, the sister, the the
brother, the baker, the policewoman, the
the head teacher to repeat the same
thing in the same way, then it builds up
that confidence in the understanding and
then it really settles down in their
brain. And that also moves us towards
the idea if you educate the child
incorrectly, it's incredibly difficult
to re-educate it. And I think that kind
of that that perspective as a child for
me has been incredibly helpful for for
getting me to be more consistent about
how I explain and how I get other people
to explain. Sorry, Chris. Cindy
>> Don, what if the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle is just more multimodal than the
artist, right? Because there's Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle backpacks and videos
and video games and all of it.
>> Yeah, maybe. I think I think it's
probably down to maybe I don't know at
that time maybe Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle was actually pretty popular, you
know, and I think there is that there
there was a
Recently I saw that Danny Sullivan had
had confirmed that an author was getting
their book shown in one of the knowledge
panels and it was because people
actually queried Stephen King books
whereas another author who was less
known wasn't actually being queried with
their name and books in together. So I
think popularity
um there will be like obviously some
seasonal aspects I suppose as well but I
think it may be also that there's just
many different ways to say the same
thing you know like Shakespeare has like
loads of different ways people say
Shakespeare you know they say his full
name his initials whatever there's
Shakespeare
>> yeah there's yeah there's Shakespeare
street Shakespeare road Shakespeare cafe
you know there's like entity
disambiguation is or determination is
obviously really important.
>> It's one of the big big challenge of
this you know large [clears throat]
scale knowledge graph. I think it's
always like about uh you know coverage
like what is the information that that
you're covering and and how correct is
this information and uh and then of
course it's it's about freshness. I
remember a caseuh a while back where uh
um a person died and uh and actually in
the panel appeared that the person had
died based on the volume of searches
that people that people were making
about that person being dead and there
was a big uh big issue because um it was
someone working in the authority of
privacy and um and and so then then then
you know the the case was kind of
dissected and Google confirmed that uh
the the amount of queries being made can
help you know the machine infer the
validity of of a fact and um and I think
that's that's that's happening more and
more. So yes, popularity is definitely
uh one aspect that uh that kind of
change how how information is is enters
into into the graph. But back to the
idea of of kind of these these uh you
know information retrieval and content
recommendation
you know what what what do you see as as
you know what's in between the two
what's what's kind of connecting the two
aspect how do you how do we think that
uh that Google is is kind of moving
between the push and pull what is using
so knowledge graph it's definitely one
very important source we're even saying
that pro possibly it's becoming a source
also for the crawler and I believe it is
I mean I was just kidding before but I
also saw for the first time that we can
let the crawler run into non-index URL
and disallow URL just by adding this URL
into the structured data without having
any link I can you know get the crawler
where it's not supposed to be only
because is in the structured data just
like Don saw and and for me it was
surprising because I've been thinking
about it that it would work this way but
now I see it on scale I see that we can
direct it even where we say you don't go
there and it will go there even if there
is no explicit link but where do you see
the connection between between the two
modalities I mean where where do you see
>> it's obviously the likes of Bert and all
the it's the it's the glue it's the it's
the uh it's the massive vast amount of
natural language in between it all so so
for me I mean for me there's definitely
It's not that we're going to move away
from information retrieval toward
recommener systems. For me, recommended
systems are just a part of information
retrieval. Like web search is just a
part of information retrieval. It's it's
and it's all part of library science.
You know, it's it's about just the
organizing of information and making
sure people can find it. So, I think
there's always that confusion that
people don't connect SEO and web search
and information retrieval. think it
literally is just one separate thing,
but it's not. It's just that's the big
umbrella type thing. Yeah.
>> But for me, there's definitely all the
improvements in natural language
understanding are the glue that helps to
hold or helps to fill in all the clues
between the disambiguation in all the
structured data. So
yeah, I mean that's the that's the gap.
That's where the big gap is, of course.
And obviously we have this move towards
uh trying to build these hybrid models
of um vectorbased or semantic based
first stage retrieval in the first
place. That seems to be like a really
big area. the whole like dense retrieval
is massive, you know, where they're
trying to actually ensure that the first
fetch of relevant candidates is much
more semantically impacted rather than
it just being based on words as such or
lexical stuff. So I think that that
that's if you get that right then that
will be a make a huge difference because
um for instance at the minute unless
you've actually got you know
like you in in first stage fetch say you
mention the word fatal but you don't
mention the word killing and the query
is around killing the chances are that
any document that just mentions fatal
might not actually be considered for
second stage and actually fine-tuning
and presenting in return in in response
to a query. Yeah. So that first stage if
they can fix that by making sure it's
more semantically driven then that will
be huge. Yeah. That will be a massive
gap bridger. Yeah, I agree a lot with
this idea that in between these push and
pull there are you know these these
embeddings or the way in which you know
we we can convert any any sense or any
media into into vectors because that's
that's the big change happening you know
from the technical point of view that's
that's what I what I see
>> but that's too expensive at the moment
still that's why they're doing the big
massive they do they do the the the
massive initial fetch in search just
based from you know if you almost like a
disregarding of a huge amount of
content.
>> Yeah.
>> So you know because of the expense.
>> Cool.
>> Right. Wonderful. Um so can can we move
on to the um how did um sorry discover
Andy you you were talking about that
because I mean the focus of this was
going to be more the push aspect. So
let's pull into the pull into the push
aspect as it were. Um you you said
you've got loads of data about Google.
Can you can you firstly just explain
what Google discover is and how it
functions and then move into the data so
that we're all clear about what we're
talking about.
>> Okay. So so Google discover is um Google
content recommendation platform and uh
and it works across uh multiple surfaces
meaning that uh you can find it on on
your iPhone devices in the form of uh
recommendation from from your Chrome
browser. You can find it into into
Android. Uh um you find it in all sorts
of places and uh and Bing has um has
introduced a very similar mechanism for
uh recommending uh content uh uh without
the user making any any query by just uh
you know pulling it on the preferences
of the user and you know the context
information as we just say. So it's a
new way of of of kind of delivering the
content that you need preemptively
without going through a query.
>> Brilliant. And the data now.
>> Yeah. So so um if I can share the
screen. I've done um these uh these
experiment. It's very preliminary, but
um
so let me let me find a way to share my
screen
and let's see if um
find going to work with these first.
Okay. Um so it's preliminary but but
interesting um because and I want to
scale it more. Okay. So what you're
seeing here is an analysis that I have
conducted on on um 10 thousands of
images coming from the API of Google
discover that is now available and that
allow us to get the data from the search
console related to to discover. So this
is a a website uh that um quite clearly
deals with video games.
So the way in which I I structured these
analysis um was to is to gather um data
from the URLs that have generated
traffic on discover and then crawl the
images for each um of these article and
um discover is very visual because uh
you know it it's a stream it's a news
stream with uh with cards uh presenting
all sort of content and of Of course uh
images do play an important role and uh
do impact the click to rate. So now here
uh what uh what I I try to do is to um
generate vectors uh using uh a model by
open AI that is called clip that has
been trained with images and text. So
generating embeddings from from images
and then uh I am also generating
embeddings from wordnet. Wordnet uh it's
it's a large dictionary of of English
words. So here I am um bringing together
um cluster of images from the traffic of
Google discover of the last uh um
we have we lost Andy.
>> Andy we can't hear you.
>> Right. We've lost Andy. His mic's still
on, but we can't hear him. Can you hear
us, Andy?
I don't think he can hear us either.
>> Oh, he was shaking his head. I think he
can.
>> Ah, right.
>> He's tiny on screen. Sorry. Go ahead,
Cindy.
>> Well, so and I've always wondered. So,
Google Discover is just the newest
version of something that Google has
been trying to work out for a really
long time. I think it started with
Google now or perhaps it's gone through
other evolutions, but it's all about um
predicting what people want to see
without actually having to have them
search. So, it's kind of like a Twitter
feed for what who Google thinks you are
and what Google thinks you care about.
And I've always wondered um there are
different things that cause you to rank
in Google Discover. And a lot of them
have to do with speed. For a while,
people thought it was only AMP pages.
Um, and but it wasn't. It was just a
speed threshold that the AMP pages were
really good at meeting. Other pages
weren't. But then there were also um
minimum requirements for the images and
um uh engagement with social media. And
so I've always wondered, is Google
Discover potentially trying to use these
different different signals to get away
from linking and rely exclusively on
these um other quality signals? Um and
and perhaps this is the test where they
say, "Can we actually um step really far
away, maybe not entirely away, um from
those kinds of quality signals that we
used to rely on with links and really
lean harder on these other signals. Um
and so I wonder Andy, if if you have if
your mic's working again, do you do you
see that as a possibility too or or you
think different?"
I I definitely see that uh you know
these are the signal that that Google is
using the most. Now I wanted to focus on
image first but uh but the the
interesting aspect of these analysis is
that I am creating a same vector space
for images and text and uh now whether
here I'm focusing primarily and almost
exclusively on images then I also run a
similar analysis on the on the text uh
of these articles but let's see what
happens. So, so here we are clustering
the images uh after analyzing each image
with with open AI clip and [snorts] and
and as you can see here we have you know
one cluster which is basically hardware
based and offer driven. This is
interesting because uh so we have a
bunch of content that it's about
specific devices and then how to acquire
these devices or the special offer of
these devices and then we have one other
cluster of content which is related or
seems to be related by looking at the
images to to FIFA and you know graphics
and EA um electronic arts uh which is
you know the publisher of of of FIFA and
then we see another concept another
cluster of uh you know these are really
kind of the the gamers and and the
Twitch world where where people kind of
exchange their own experience while they
while they play. And then of course you
have the you know the typical uh counter
fire raid zone siege and
counterterrorist. Now these are terms
that uh that that are similar and that
are extracted from wordnet and then
combined with this cluster and then you
have you know these um
um you know other other cluster of of
elements like you know the the Pokemon
kind of side and all the all the imagery
that comes from these games. Now this is
the stuff that we have on on discover
and uh and now I I have done you know
the same um analysis and uh and I will
just share uh another screen where we
can see um the the same the same
analysis applied to the traffic of the
web and I want to see if you if you can
uh uh kind of see the difference. Uh let
me let me share this um this other uh
part.
So here you have uh you know the same
site but the traffic is coming from from
you know the traditional search and uh
and and you might see that you know
there are some some cluster that are
similar like the FIFA cluster it's it's
there uh and then the war uh cluster is
here and then you know the the Pokemon
cluster is here and this one you know
it's kind of a mix between the the
hardware and uh and maybe Grant proud
of.
>> So what it's missing and and what is
making the difference really it's the
the social part. So the the the cluster
of of images coming from from Twitch
it's what it's making the difference
between you know the two the two areas
and uh and also the the the the content
that is related to the to the device and
to the offers it's appearing on discover
but it doesn't appear on on search. Now
this makes a lot of sense because people
usually don't look for you know their
favorite gamer on on you know on Google
by making a query. It's not something
that we search. It's most likely
something that we are provided with as
you know it kind of resonates with our
interest. And so I was uh uh very much
interested in seeing well first that
there are some pieces of content that
could last in discover up to eight days
whether usually traffic on discovery you
know kind of goes for for 48 hours. Um I
could see that in some cases you know
the exposure goes a lot longer as long
as eight days consecutive. The other
aspect is that uh there are chunks of
the website that don't get much
visibility on traditional search but
they do a tremendous visibility on
discover and especially these are in
this specific context you know um
information related to to to tweets and
uh and and kind of videos of people
gaming which are in any case hard to
find from a search engine perspective
and no one is really searching for them.
>> Brilliant. Wow. crumbs. And so kind of
from from that perspective, what what
what what should we be doing with our
content to to push it towards discover?
>> So well, I mean the basic stuff as as
Sydney was was suggesting, I mean there
are different signals that we can use
and uh and uh you know definitely high-
res images and uh and uh you know catchy
titles. I also analyze you know all the
content and by analyzing the content I
could see with the same you know within
the same um contextual space by reading
all the content and extracting you know
the topics with with language models I
could see that the cluster were pretty
much the same again on one side the word
zone and the terrorist uh side of
content and on the other side you know
the social twitch uh YouTube video
recording um but so one one important
aspect is that the content that we
prepare for for discover might not be
the content that works well on search
and the content that works well on
discover it's content that can be more
uh easy to be socialized.
>> Right? So, we're coming back to that
idea of kind of social media. It's that
similar idea of pushing to me the things
I'd be interested in, such as the famous
gamer who plays some video game all day
long that I want to watch his video,
which seems as an old person pretty
weird, but there you go.
>> That's an I mean, it's a different
domain. It took me a while to understand
these chats, but then I Okay, [laughter]
>> in the future. So if you think about the
Twitch um scenario, there are people who
randomly will start streaming on Twitch
versus people who have kind of a regular
schedule. And let's say, you know, um
every week, so uh Andy watches this same
person play on their regular schedule,
but then every week also um Andy watches
this other thing on Google TV on a
totally different topic. Um, since it's
all based on um your personal behavior
plus plus plus other things, it could
then start to remind you like, "Hey
Andy, click this button and you'll
stream um the Twitch thing to your big
TV or click this button because we know
you're just about to watch, you know,
blah blah blah that you watch every
single week." And so it's going to be
really the glue and the the integrating
force um that that really starts to
become like the remote control for your
life. But I think one one important
thing that I want to add to this
discussion is that is the kind of the
elephant in the room or at least my
favorite elephant in the room and that
is that that um discover is only mobile.
>> Why true
>> that seems important. Why? Because it's
going to be the glue. Or at least in my
mind, the the the thing that say makes
this device do that and this device do
that. And same with the TV. If you
normally change your heat settings on
your Nest thermostat, then it might
start to um recommend that or it might
pull in the weather feed and say, "Hey,
it's going to get extra cold tonight. Do
you want to adjust your settings?"
Right? These are this I think if I had
to guess would be the long-term vision.
>> I think I think there will definitely be
a temporal aspect to it as well in that
for instance if somebody's interested in
the stock market at certain times it's
going to like recommend it's going to
come back with stock market content. So
but for me the gaming aspect I mean I
don't know many gamers that play games
on their mobile. Yeah. So I think it
will be ultimately
I don't know as you say it depends on
how you define mobile because mobile is
potentially TV TV a device and maybe it
is that transition from mobile just the
handheld traditional phone that we see
into all of these other devices over
time. So
>> well and Don have you seen that Google's
trying to stand up stand up a competitor
to the cloud version of PlayStation
Network? Right.
>> So I do I do think that that's part of
it.
>> Yeah. But
Maybe
maybe that's the next step. All of these
different devices together.
>> Yeah. Well, and I don't know if you
remember what, but when mobile first
indexing first came out, I redefined
mobile as portable. Google wants
portable content
um that can move from one device to
another easily, not necessarily just a
handset. It's kind of the old before we
had mobile phones meaning of the word
mobile.
>> That's a good definition.
>> Yeah. Well, especially with the, you
know, the the likes of Google Home now,
more and more of those have got screens
on.
>> Yep.
>> You know, uh more and more people
obviously getting them. I've got four in
here. Should not mention that word
because it always chips in all the time.
But um yeah maybe and the likes of
competing with YouTube ultimately in
across every single opportunity to
communicate with humans. So
>> but then from that perspective Cindy
mobile's coming to desk desktop.
Yeah, absolutely. I think that's
actually because because progressive web
apps started as a mobile only and now um
you can add the progressive web apps on
your computer and I do think that at
some point we'll see a Google discover
on um desktop. I don't see why not
because you can cast from your desktop
as well. Um, so yeah, I think that it is
actually being um mobile first in a very
loose definition of all of those words.
>> I wonder whether people will just stop
talking about mobile in the end because
it just won't won't even be something we
think about. You know, the fact that
it's literally it's literally just this
is just the way it is. You know, it's
everywhere. It's all around us. There's
no def differentiation between the
desktop experience and the mobile
experience, etc. I think I think the
term will change over time.
>> It fades into the background in the same
way that people don't realize that
Facebook is part of the internet, you
know, like I'm going on the internet.
Oh, I'm going to go on Facebook. As if
that's different.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. It would just
all become for me it just will all
become half one and the same thing.
>> Yeah.
>> Just always there. There's always the
assistant there. There's always, you
know, you I wouldn't dream of putting a
uh switching on a CD to play music
anymore, you know. It's I've got my
Spotify on my phone. I've got it when
I'm running. I've got it, you know, in
my Google Home. I've got it everywhere.
So, you know,
>> well, people I think younger generations
will say, "I'm going to watch TV." And
what they mean is they're going to watch
YouTube.
>> Exactly.
>> Wonderful. Um, right. Brilliant. So, uh,
Cindy, you said you had loads of data as
well to share. Do you want to do that to
to move the conversation to a different
slightly different topic?
>> Yeah. So, I have two things that I that
I'd like to show. So, let me see if I
can do what Andy did did and do a
backto-back show and tell really quick.
Um, the first thing that I want to show
is just a little piece of a presentation
that I did. Um, and hopefully I can get
this right. So,
share screen.
I think I'm just going to have to do
And
>> that's coming. Yep. Looks so good.
>> Go like this.
>> It's loading. And now we can see it.
>> Oh, we can see that you're Oh,
brilliant.
>> This bigger. So Jason, I knew you would
like this um because it's branded
results. And so what we do is a little
bit different from what you do. We take
fulllength screen captures of queries
and we can track knowledge graph results
specifically with their um KG URL. So
this one because they can be different.
The knowledge graph can change on its
own but then the knowledge graph as it
sits in a branded search result um can
be a slightly different thing. So this
is the knowledge graph as it sits in a
branded search result. Knowledge graph
for GrubHub and you can see we're
checking it every single day.
And so what I share in this um
presentation is just how different it is
from daytoday on the branded result. You
get that it's a branded result because
you have this heading at the top. Um but
first we get the website and then we get
the knowledge graph and then next day
changes knowledge graph first. Then next
day changes to a different presentation
of the website with horizontal uh
indented links instead of vertical. And
then um this is just the the next couple
of days. It looks like this. And the
differences are it goes back to the
vertical with three um and knowledge
graph below. Then back to the website,
but now there's a picture. And then
below it is uh the website again with
some um FAQ dropdowns. And then the next
day is the website first with only one
indented link and a search box. Um, and
so this is what it looks like over time.
We're we're seeing these branded results
can change quite dramatically.
Um, just from one day to the next. And I
wanted to see Jason, is this something
that you're also looking at or is it
you're looking at it a different way?
>> Um, no, we're not actually looking at
the um specific order more the the
results because we're focusing on uh how
how well can you control and optimize.
So, this is phenomenally interesting.
Um, the way we're doing it is using
Authoritas's API, pulling it in, and we
can obviously put them in the right
order, but I never thought to look at
that on a day-to-day basis. We do track
for our clients day-to-day, but now
you've just wasted my weekend because
I'll spend the weekend trying to trying
to see if our data demonstrates the same
thing or whether we're going to have to
start to take screenshots for for our
clients.
How much of of these changes are
according to you uh dependent on on
Google running tests to increase
clickthrough rate and how much are
dependent on you know the context
changing because maybe the brand has has
published something new or there is
something on the horizon that justifies
that change? I mean do you have any
idea?
>> Well I think that with the big brands
like like GrubHub they can get lots of
test data in really quickly. So, I do
agree that they're probably testing. Um,
but I wanted to show you um something
else, too. So, this is what it looks
like. And we can you can see we have all
these g.co URLs. This is for tracking a
specific um a specific GMBB landing
page. That's what those um URLs look
like. But in this one, we've got a
specific knowledge graph um that that
we're testing and it's just for FIFA.
And so we can see the history like this
and get the full screenshot and then go
back in history um to see how it's
changed. So in this one it's interesting
because it changes from just saying FIFA
with the logo and then having some um
kind of disambiguation pill buttons up
here and then now they explain or they
spell out what does FIFA stand for. And
so you can see Google has learned
something between 81 and 91.
They've built that out. And so that's
another thing that I think is going to
be more and more important for companies
to start tracking is their own um
knowledge graph to see when does Google
actually learn something and understand
and like what's coming in as the people
also search for a and just seeing them
side by side. You can see that the
people also search for changes from
month to month, right? And that also
speaks to how Google potentially
understands the the relationships. And
so I I think that
um I call it like reality mining is
looking at real results instead of just
looking at numbers to know what's
changed. Um can be potentially a big
deal. Like this is another one where you
can see the history um and this one
doesn't change as much but for instance
the pictures change you know from one to
another and so knowing when the pictures
in the knowledge graph are changing or
when the dropdowns GrubHub um has a
bunch of dropdowns that change quite
regularly. So, that's kind of I'm I'm
looking at it slightly differently from
you guys. Um because I really um
I want to know what Google's testing and
why to kind of guess what they're going
to go with
>> and what's going to actually work and
drive the most interest in the Google
SER itself. Uh because Google has an
interest in not necessarily getting
people to websites but keeping people on
Google content
>> of course.
>> So I'll stop sharing. That's my that's
my show and tell.
>> That that's really brilliant. And and
the other thing Cindy that that kind of
you will have noticed as well is that
they the knowledge panels changed vastly
over Geo region as well. So you've got
over time and I I think kind of as Andy
said a lot of what you've just shown
might be experimentation or especially
the big brands which is a brilliant
insight and I think what a lot of big
brands don't realize is that across
different countries the knowledge panel
can change significantly um and for with
Cali cube that's what we're looking at
as well is is how much does this change
over regions and the people also search
for you can actually see which other
entities Google's associating with the
entity itself and the one I used was
Netflix and the perceived competition
perhaps we could say uh is very
different in the UK to to what it is in
the in the US. Um and I've actually got
a a slide for that which I can pull up
if I may.
I've got to figure out like Cindy how to
go about this. There we go. And if I go
back here, this is part of a a
presentation I give. Um, that's not the
screen I was looking to show you. I was
looking to show you. Now I've got to
find it. Um, and I've lost it. I do
apologize. Oh, it's right at the top.
Um, looking here. Um, there we go.
Right. Um, knowledge knowledge panels on
brand surfs. We've got 18,723
brands in the colle
uh that we track in the US. 51% have got
knowledge panels and that was 43% two
years ago. So there's a growth in
potentially understanding or at least
confidence in that understanding. I
would suggest both. Uh and it's actually
universal across the world. If you look
at these other angophone countries, it's
98% of them will also appear in the
other countries. Um but the
international variations, what's
relevant in a given country changes
vastly. And you can see here um we're
looking at the attributes. 've got 2567
unique attributes for companies that
Google shows as attributes and I've got
a thing for the sources for that which
is pretty interesting. But here you can
see the customer service number. That's
an obvious one that will change
according to country and Google's
actually getting much better at that
from what I can see. But also what in
what information people are interested
in. I mean apparently in the US people
are interested in the chainsaw mix ratio
is still chainsaw but in the UK they're
more interested in who the other
companies are. uh within that group. And
if you look at IKA, then you've got the
pro the social media profiles. They're
doing relatively well, but there's still
a bit of a mixup. This is a phenomenally
big problem for for brands is being able
to communicate to Google which social
profile to show in which country if they
have a social media profile dedicated to
that country. Uh and I think a lot of
big companies don't actually know what
they have, let alone are able to
communicate it correctly to Google. It's
also interesting in the previous stream
you had um for IKEA you had um you know
on in UK again you know the parent
organizations
and on the other one you had actually
the opposite which is the subsidiary
>> right yeah wow how very strange oh well
right and then this was the example for
the for the different competitors for
Netflix brilliant point Andy um is that
in the US we're looking at Amazon Prime
Disney Hulu Instagram WhatsApp but in
the UK HBO for some reason which I would
have thought would have been American
but also Amazon and Apple YouTube and
Tuby. Um I mean I don't know to the at
this point how much of insight that is,
how much it's competition and how much
it's close relationships in Google's
little brain. Um but
>> you don't have HBO in UK right Don?
>> Uh I don't think he's popular if it is
even here to be honest. So it must be a
close relationship as opposed to a
competition.
>> So for me for me this kind of all just
feels as though it's it's it's just
dynamic search. It's like an equivalent
in the knowledge graph of dynamic search
results ranking. So based on the
probability that this audience is
interested in X Y and Zed because
>> there's no point showing obviously a US
number in the UK and so forth. So I
think it's just that I think this is all
just ultimately fine-tuning for a
dynamic audience and like moving away
from that if you like the holy grail of
I which is the probability ranking
principle based on just relevance alone.
And this is for me
taking documents together rather than or
knowledge graph items together and
assembling them as one rather than
ranking them or placing them all
independently if that makes sense. So
how can these all mix together? And
presumably that all just comes from like
learning to graph and learning to rank
in SERs or you know machine learning and
knowledge graphs as such
>> right which I mean and and that's that's
really interesting. It also means that
kind of that that people also search for
and that here the film's produced is
going to be one of the more difficult
things to start to manage the rest of
the profiles and the attributes and the
description relle even that you
mentioned earlier on s Cindy relatively
simple to manage but um those those kind
of groupings are going to be difficult
to manage especially as they're probably
also driven or driven in a in a in a
large part by the the query pool um and
we see trending a lot of the time in
those people also search a trending
topic or a trending entity will come to
the top and then it will disappear
again. Um and the mutuality between
those trending topics isn't there. We
saw Will Smith I think it was had
somebody trending in his people also
asked people also search for when you
clicked on that person he wasn't
trending on theirs. So obviously that
trending situation is incredibly uh
individualized and
>> but there's going to be a nearest
neighbor there's going to be definitely
a nearest neighbor aspect to all right
>> I know whether you'd agree with that
Andy but the def there there will be
like a nearest I mean ultimately the
nearest neighbor in the US knowledge
graph is is probably very very different
to the ones in the UK knowledge graph
>> sure and I mean this data shows just how
much it does change across different
countries uh from the UK and the US is
that all five are different 5% of the
time. None of them are different only
28% of the time in our data set which
does show that Google is is
very much geo sensitive in the knowledge
panels. Sorry Andy, do you want to
comment on what?
>> No, it makes total sense. It makes total
sense. Well,
I was going to say I'm talking about
nearest neighbor, not from a geo
perspective, but from a nearest neighbor
similarity search,
>> right? Yeah. Yeah. Sure.
>> Especially especially in these in this
idea that that all the meanings from,
you know, the different sources are
coming into one. I think that's the big
change in search is that you know
whatever data source you have at in the
end it's it's coming into into one set
of results and uh and that's that's
that's the you know when when I was
asking before uh you know what's the
connecting dot between push and pull and
and don you know said you know it's it's
in the end it's it's birth and embedded
that are kind of making possible to
bring everything on on the same level
and that's that's very transformative
you know compared to the way in which
search has been has been working in the
last 20 years.
>> Well, if it's okay, I'd like to just add
in the kind of maybe observation that
might be obvious to all of us but maybe
not to the listeners is that this does
seem to be at least in my perspective
um kind of the future of where the SEO
industry is headed. Um because um
knowing exactly what uh ranking you
have, it's going to get more and more
diverse and more and more personalized
over time. And so what what's going to
be the stable thing is probably going to
be these knowledge graph understandings
um and optimizing those and having that
trickle down to website traffic and
other asset traffic. And I think that
there's there's an interesting side note
with the non-website traffic, the
multiaceted multimodal traffic is that
we can't ignore that Google has
introduced Google and Bing um and other
search engines have introduced this um
indexing API
that allows for indexing without
crawling links per se. There may need to
be a unique URL or a unique URI, but for
instance, that also speaks to this
multimodal nature of where search is
headed where Google wants to be able not
only to rank the right page on a
website, but also the right screen in an
app or think about mapping within a
YouTube video, mapping your chapters.
They want to be able to rank the right
chapter in a video or I think that's
going to extend to podcast. the right
section of a podcast
um be and those things can't
traditionally be crawled but they could
be indexed if we uh submit them through
an indexing API and same with native
apps um and PWAs um the move towards an
indexing API does speak to this um
knowledge graph as the primary thing and
websites
as one possible modifier um amongst
other modifiers that are other modes of
information. Does that does that
resonate with you or am I crazy?
>> I think it makes no makes a lot of
sense. Also what [clears throat] I'm
noticing so one one aspect is of course
the longtail is becoming predominant
because there are a lot of you know
longtail searches popping up because as
we as you know the the meanings are
being extracted from the documents in in
in all the different forms then we can
really get into the longtail. The other
aspect is that as you show um you know
tracking and kind of evaluating
SEO positioning has changed so much. I
mean it does it really make sense to
kind of evaluate SEO as we've done so
far? Possibly not. I mean we need to
kind of look at search in a different
way and as you say what stays is
probably you know the representation of
the entity inside the graph. then you
know the form that it takes it's going
to be highly personalized and super
different from one day to another you
know from one query to another so it's
you know the traditional SEO tools that
measure the results and the keyword
positioning are you know pretty much
limited in the way in which we we can
understand the data so and and and this
is also I think a big challenge for the
industry I think both you and Jason are
trying to cope with these problems
because you're trying to understand okay
on one side JSON is kind of diving deep
into the into the graph and it's is it
wants to provide that type of
information you're providing another
information which is how the graph is
being represented and um but but you
know the traditional SEO tools um even
if they are super advanced in in in the
data acquisition that they have
currently lack the ability of
understanding you know what's the data
behind that is driving these results and
that's that's a big issue I think for
the industry in general general that
that you know tools like yours and
Jason's are trying to to address.
>> Yeah. Right. 100%. I mean we K we're
digging into the graph but we're trying
to do what Cindy's doing as well. Um in
in the sense but from a a commercial
perspective looking at brands and saying
this is what your audience is seeing. Uh
but also more than that it's it's what
Google's understanding to be relevant
and helpful to your audience. And if you
don't agree with Google's judgment on
it, then you need to take a good look in
the mirror and start thinking what it is
it I'm doing wrong. Either I'm producing
the wrong content or my audience aren't
engaging or Google isn't seeing that
engagement so it doesn't realize that
it's important. And
>> there's also, you know, the data gap,
you know, the the the data gap. It's big
because at the moment, if I look at, you
know, the search data from the search
console, I'm pretty much limited to see,
you know, just clicks and impressions.
But the game has changed. they still see
the position even though the position is
no longer there. For instance, in mobile
you know we we we are all on the same
page but uh but the data hasn't been
updated. So that's why you know I I I I
spent uh you know some time to elaborate
a new method to see okay how can I
analyze the traffic data and augment it
and try to cluster together and try to
see if there are some some patterns that
can indicate you know that if I generate
more social related content maybe I will
get more traffic from from from
discover. So we we need to change the
way in which we look at you know the
search data. Well, so share my screen
again because I I think we've made
headway into this and I want to kind of
get you guys's opinion on this. Um, is
that we are looking at some different
metrics um that I think are going to
become more important for from an SEO
perspective
um because what we're doing here like
for this query Adidas so it's also a
branded query um possibly misspelled No,
it's right. And so what we do on the the
SER datalyzer is we're grabbing again
these things over time, daily, weekly or
monthly, but we also parse the re the
real thing. And so we can show you the
actual rank, which um versus the
traditional rank. Traditional rank is
what SEOs have used forever which I
think is a misrepresentation versus
actual rank which counts everything
including ads including knowledge graph
including people also ask everything
that's in there gets a number and so
then you see the website the first
website is actual rank for traditional
rank one but you also get pixels from
the top and the percent of SER and we
let people claim a listing so that as an
SEO you get credit not just for your
website ranking but also if you show up
in a knowledge graph if you show up in
your Facebook or in the image carousel
you can claim these things and say this
is also mean and then you get an overall
score which this one's not set up but a
moxy score for how much of the SER you
own and then the mess score is like how
hard is it to rank in this SER in the
first place and that's like how much is
Google owning of this SER basically the
mess score so hard
>> the mass score is uh is Google managing
so like uh advertising and uh YouTube uh
right
>> so score is like should you even try
right like Google owns 60% of this page
>> maybe try something that where you have
more potential to get traffic
>> so it's obviously difficulty score
effectively
>> effectively a difficulty score
>> I like the name
>> difficulty score when you're competing
against the owner of the the actual
search engine, Google,
>> right? [laughter]
>> Which is a lost
>> score. It's good. Me score is a good
name.
Yeah, I like a lot this direction
because sometimes it gets hard to to
otherwise explain the results in terms
of you know clicks when maybe the you
know the average position hasn't changed
but then you see a dramatic change in
the clicks and then you realize that you
know there are more objects on that SER
that are kind of changing the the
behavior of the user. your traditional
ranking can stay the same for a long
time, but your actual rank and the
pixels the pixels from the top can
change dramatically and that's going to
impact clickthrough. And I'm tired of
SEOs kind of pretending that those
things don't matter or that ads aren't
taking clicks and pushing you down the
page. Like we need to look at reality
and those things do take clicks.
>> I was going to say and that's a dynamic
intent. I mean when you look at it a SER
if you go and look as a human you see
the descending order of intent intent
detection on any query in the actual
first page of the SER you know it's
there is completely there you can see if
it's like the most comprehensive
you know if you if you're dealing in
fashion you can see whether the search
engines determined whether it's a
genderless or a gendered query you can
see whether it's aformational query or
you know it's it's just really obvious
as well and that's going to change all
the time. So for for people to think
that they can nail on positions is is
just insane because that's not how it
works.
>> Right. Should we come back to knowledge
graphs and uh Google learning rather
than search which is the focus I think
for this I mean that was I'm not
criticizing that was absolutely
delightful and wonderful. Um the next
the one of the next questions was big
moments. I mean, I hadn't really heard
about this and Andy put this in the in
the presentation. So, Andy has the
responsibility of saying what it is and
then asking the questions. Well, I mean,
Big Moments is one of these um kind of
brand names for um several algorithms
that are trying to cluster content
related to a given event because of
course uh again uh uh Google is
realizing that uh when when when
something is happening, people move away
from traditional search experiences and
look for uh kind of real time data. So
moments at the moment is is is is a name
that uh that um you know it will it will
kind of describe what Google is is doing
for representing information about a
given topic and and its evolution over
time whether this is uh you know the the
pandemic or or a sube event uh in a
specific location. how you know Google
can can can harness the data and and
present something fresh to the user of
course in a queryless form in most
cases. So that's kind of the you know
the the evolution once again how can we
help you know the Google knowledge graph
in understanding you know that that this
is something happening and that we're
able to report it and of course there
are a lot of uh properties in structured
data that have been also introduced for
kind of live reporting and live coverage
and you know the publishing date of a
specific event and where the event has
happened and so I think that this is
also an area of search that uh it's
currently underexplored, but it's
becoming bigger if if we're moving more
into, you know, this stream of content
that is recommended based on, you know,
user location and context.
>> Brilliant. Wonderful. How much do you
know about that, Dor?
>> Can't hear you. Sorry.
>> Not a huge amount.
probably knows more about that than I do
at this moment in time to be honest.
>> Not you drive,
>> right? I mean because that that's just
kind of brought me straight on to to
something else that that's kind of made
me think about salency in the knowledge
graph
>> and the fact that
>> well the fact I mean how first of all
how does the knowledge graph actually
how do we fill how do we educate Google?
How do we fill up the knowledge graph?
one question and the other question is I
was looking at um knowledger graph
salency or confidence scores the result
score that the knowledger graph API
returns um and it's it's kind of curious
because a it has the the the average
score doesn't change there is a set of
kind of marbles that Google design
divides up between all the entities so
entities move up and down but it's
always relative to other entities second
thing that just occurred to me is I was
looking at the Beatles
And the salency score for the Beatles,
what's lovely is Ringo started
completely flat. It never changes.
John Lennon, his salience salency score
went through the roof last January. And
I was wondering why. And it turns out it
was the anniversary of his death in
December. And so there was an awful lot
of news about it. Same thing happened to
George Harrison when there was a
re-release of one of his albums in
September of the year before. Jason,
four candles. Remember four candles.
>> Four candles. The two Ronny's sketch
went through the roof when they both
died. That that that individual entity,
four candles. So when Ronnie Barker
died, four candles went up massively.
>> Brilliant.
>> So that is very similar to when people
die, things just become very very
strong.
>> Well, and there's a lot of news around
it. the the that's a brilliant example
and it's your favorite one, isn't it?
Fort Gandles for
>> candles for ages.
>> And the thing I love about the Beatles
is that Ringo Star is always kind of
totally constant and it represents his
his personality as well. But but it also
>> unusual name as well. So I mean John,
anything with John,
>> you know, I went I was dentist this
morning before John's my husband my dog.
No, not my dog. Sorry, my husband. my
dentist dentist's assistant and the the
another guy in reception. It was very
confusing. So, anybody with the name of
John, it's not gonna there's not going
to be a huge amount of confidence on any
search engine.
>> Right. And I mean for for John Lennon,
the salency score actually went up very
significantly. Same for George Harrison.
And we had the same thing for Paul
McCartney at one point. I think it was
another album release. But what just
struck me is that saliency score is
perhaps pushing towards the idea of
newsworthiness at a given time and
therefore pushing into big moments which
would mean that I mean from my
perspective building up my own salency
score or confidence score or result
score. What I've seen is once you get to
about 500 it's very difficult to push it
higher. Once you get to a thousand it
becomes increasingly difficult and my
book publisher said to me you're a
D-Level celebrity which is delightful.
Uh, and as a D-Level celebrity, however
much noise I make around our little
industry, I'm pushing it up by two to
three points at best each time. And
that's with consistent, as we said with
Cali Cub, or I said with Cali Cube, I'm
pushing and pushing and pushing. It's my
name on everything. Pushing up by three
little points each time. So that that
that roof sorry ceiling is really
difficult to start breaking. So
newsworthiness within my industry
potentially if I can associate myself
with the correct topics in a global
sense to t two excuse me of French
always kind of that D-level um celebrity
and one last point about the salency
score that struck me the state bank of
India has one of the highest salency
scores we've ever seen because there are
a billion people in India and a large
number of them have accounts and talk
about the state bank of India so the
state bank of India compared to Google
is obviously kind of not as important on
a global scale but in terms of the
number of people talking about it it's
phenomenally important guys are tool
sorry go ahead
>> I think that you know what we see is
that in order to infuse knowledge in a
knowledge graph you know we we Google
leverages on conversation
>> right
>> and uh and then Google leverages on
search volumes and so if there is
something happening and people are
searching for that and confirming that
of course there is an interest and then
of course now we have a lot of question
and answer pairs that are also kind of
driving these uh you know knowledge
inside inside the knowledge graph. So
these again moments or or or discover
are you know these uh this idea of
moving from from search to conversation
or from search to to a news feed.
>> I think also as well you know there is
there is click data that is also feeding
machine. I mean have you heard of orcas?
You heard of the orcas clicked data set
that's been gifted from by by Microsoft
which is literally queries and what the
URLs that got clicked
>> to deter I it's free you can get to it
actually if you're doing research which
you are it's literally called orers and
there's a video on it and the guy from
Microsoft says look click data tells us
what the user meant when they clicked on
something it's not about ranking higher
It's about understanding when there's
like, you know, if you if you have the
word orers, you could have like several
different meanings. Did it mean the
whale? Did you mean this data set? That
kind of thing. So click data is this is
what the user meant. So actually now
researchers have got access to things
like that. I mean the last time click
data was available is a very long time
ago. Now [clears throat]
there's huge a huge bank of it. So that
will also be being fed in by the likes
of the MS Marco researchers and all the
AI machine learning natural language
processing uh researchers as well. So
I'll share a link to that.
>> Yeah, please do. That's interesting.
Completely.
>> Yeah, I mean and and Nathan Charas from
Bing who's the whole page algorithm guy
was talking to me about how important
click click data is for them. And
basically I I was talking to Ali Alvie
who does the features. They put the the
the Q&A for for Bing and when I said,
"Oh, there's a very strange thing going
on." He's basically said, "Well, that's
Nathan Char's messing with our results
and Nathan was basically saying, I take
it, look at the clickthrough data, and
then I just reorganize it in in a
Darwinistic manner." And their algorithm
is actually called Darwin, interestingly
enough. Um, so that that kind of click
data is the overriding ending that where
he says, "We're designing our product,
which is so powerful."
>> Exactly. That's that's the first p
that's the first page of SERs. You know,
the click data is the intent and the
SERs are the descending order of intent
on a query
>> or they get Yeah.
>> And that's probably what's happening
with that Cindy as well. It's
>> it's dynamically
>> Yeah.
>> descending order of intent given a
audience in a location and with a
particular context. Well, let's wonder
too at what point do we think Google
will have a googly experience on every
SER? like have they decided that
salience
um is variable by the query or by the
person and that we can throw a knowledge
graph in to almost every query or we can
throw people also ask into almost every
query because Jason with your story
about salience my first question is do
you think you would get more salience
like people are talking about you and
your book in this limited community but
the question of salience is salience to
the average person
uh of which you're very important to the
SEO community um and a couple other
communities the music community but to
the rest of the world you might need to
get links or mentions from New York
Times or something like that that says
you're not just an SEO
um and you're not just relevant or
salient to an SEO
um
>> like two ideas How how is salience
modified and is it query specific? And
do we think that Google is going to try
and have a super rich experience for 80%
of the queries and leave 20% as just
blue links or do they have a different
kind of when do they stop? How do they
know when they're done?
>> That kind of question. Well, I mean, the
blue links question is I I thought I I
at one point said, "Oh, blue links are
dying out." And then I talked to
Frederick Doo from Bing, who's the blue
link algorithm guy there, and he was
saying, "Oh, no, no, it's it's been
stable for years, and it won't it will
be stable for the foreseeable future."
And our data indicates that it is
stable, but there are more rich elements
over the last couple of years, but
basically, it's in brand SERs. This is
purely brand surfs, eight blue links on
average, and it's gone up from 1.2 two
uh rich elements, what I'm call features
rich elements to about well over two to
two 2.4. So what's happening is the SERs
are getting longer with these extra rich
elements, but the blue links aren't
dying out. And the reasoning he gave
behind that was we can't kill off the
blue links because they're the found the
foundation of our entire business model,
which is the ads at the top.
>> Yeah, exactly. I mean, it's it's just a
matter of finding an alternative
business model that that would allow
Google to monetize the information in a
different way. I mean until we have uh
you know the advertising that we have
but if you think about you know
advertising on channels like discover
then then you're going to start thinking
that you know there is a different level
of estate that that Google can sell and
uh that doesn't require the links. So
and and also the you know the what we
the first um expression of of Google mom
it also gives us the indication that uh
search is becoming conversational
>> and where does it stop you know where
where where would it stop again it's
it's a it's a question of business
models I believe rather than you know
technology
>> but it's just a different aspect for me
they'll always need something like the
links because most queries are
underspecified
You say the word Harry Potter, what the
user want? They want everything. They
want the show, they want the book, they
want the video, they want to want the
knowledge go. So you have to fill the 10
blocks with all the different intents in
descending order of predicted intent in
a location given a context, users,
search history, etc. So you can't do
that with one or two answers. You've got
to have a richness of experience and
those are the slots in the 10 blue
links. Right. But when when when the
intent is defined, you know, and we see,
for instance, in e-commerce when when,
you know, I'm trying to to buy a pair
of, you know, that shoes or, you know,
that specific uh product, then Google is
pulling this product knowledge graph
panel that uh it's pretty comprehensive
and uh almost exclusive of of the other
links because it's combining, you know,
all the information about the product,
the reviews, and you know, the different
vendors with the prices. So of course
when the intent gets more defined then
of course the the templates kind of lose
their importance for for dismbigration
>> right and if I can share my screen that
what you were talking about dawn now is
with entity searches such as Harry
Potter now what we're getting once
Google's understood the entity we're
searching for once again going back to
brand search I'm afraid if I can share
my screen
>> y
>> please I'm trying I'm waiting for the
screen to come up it's it's the filter
pills that they've started adding uh in
America that I absolutely utely love. I
think they're great, but obviously not
great for click-through rate, but then
it's a branded search, so maybe it's not
important. But if you see here, the East
Bay Ray is my favorite punk guitarist
from when I was a kid from the Dead
Kennedys. That's the knowledge panel we
traditionally see around the world. On
the right, we've seen these filter pills
coming up on the left hand side. That's
Brian Seter, another hero of mine. Um,
and now what what Google's doing and
these filter pills that I've been
working on is you get them across the
top which is much more like mobile. So
mobile is coming to desktop is uh
already the case. And basically it's
allowed me for Harry Potter it would be
similar. It' be digging down into the
videos, the TV shows, the books. For me
it's lesson songs and albums. Um, and
those all then become vertical
sorry vertical brand SERs that I can dig
down into. If you look at the songs
here, it's got a list of my songs and
it's up to me to feed this information
to Google as part in my opinion of part
of the knowledge panel and part of
Google's understanding of the entities
around it is to trigger those filter
pills, trigger those vertical results
and control the vertical results. um
which is going to be a new challenge for
for all brands at least in the brand SER
space and and that kind of idea of in
that circumstance the blue links are
suddenly not very important because I'm
going to be as a user knowledge panel
hopping
>> from knowledge from information to
information sorry
>> you can imagine Jason you can imagine in
your example how that interaction would
play out in a voice query like let's say
we're in a car yelling at Google
Assistant um or Android Auto through
Google Assistant whatever. And you say,
"Um,
okay. Device, uh, tell me about Jason
Bernard." And it brings up that with the
filter pills. And the filter pills
become your multiple choice question.
Would you like to see more about would
you like to see videos of Jason Bernard?
Would you like to have audio of Jason
Bernard? Would you like to do this? And
so it becomes the chatbot, right? the
SER or the knowledge graph with the
filter pills
>> is the chatbot that interacts with you
without the blue links at all.
>> Yeah.
>> And my my vision is that that's what
Google kind of wants for 80% of the
queries and just 20% are going to be
mostly blue links and the rest are going
to be at least have that possibility of
a deeply interactive rich experience.
>> Brilliant. But again, again, I think I
think it will just be all all of these
things. Blue Links to me is going to
stay. There's there's not there's not a
limit to where all of this can go
because obviously they just still with
Google Home, there's still a lot of
people who haven't even got them. You
know, there's lots of people there's the
world is huge and there's lots of ways
in which search engines can get further
into people's homes and into people's
lives. you know, there's only two cars,
two makes and models of cars, I think,
that that actually have Google Home
built in now. Um, so there's there's all
of these different platforms everywhere.
And I I don't think it's one of it's a
case of one or the other. I think
everything it's a bit like when people
say, "Oh, throw the desktop out because
everything's mobile first." No. Nobody's
going to sit down and fill out a
mortgage application form on a mobile on
their phone. Yeah.
Certain things you still do on either
you I don't and can't even imagine
people sat down doing it on their TV.
Certain people sit down at a computer or
at a desk by a laptop and they'll fill
in a mortgage application form. Yeah.
>> So just horses for courses for me.
>> It could it could absolutely be additive
or it could be device specific
experiences. When you're on a desktop
you get more blue links. when you're on
Android Auto, you get only knowledge
graph kinds of results. But I wonder
too, I think this is an interesting
analogy, Jason, from the perspective of
branded results
>> is like when mobile phones um took off,
all of us collectively forgot how to
memorize someone's phone number.
>> Yep.
>> Um and um we just pushed a button. And
now that
>> now that we have um connected TVs or
voice remotes where you can say watch
this, no one knows what channel things
are on anymore or at least they don't
know the numeric channel. [snorts] And
so I wonder how much of this kind of um
amnesia is going to affect brands and
their domains.
>> Right.
>> Right. Google knows all. Do we need to
know the domain of our favorite band or
our favorite personality or TV show?
Maybe not. Um,
>> yeah.
>> Do but do we want to give Google all
that power to or do we have a choice?
>> I don't think we have a choice. It's
going to take it whether you like it or
not. And I mean from our perspective,
our responsibility is to educate the
child that is Google about our little
corner of the internet and then try to
do the best we can. I mean we're not
going to change Google's course of
action uh but we we can potentially
improve our own situation within it.
Yeah, it is also true that uh you know
uh search engine like star page uh or or
you know duck.go or now you.com are are
kind of you know on the growth side
meaning that you know there are also
people that are kind of getting out of
these gated experience and u you know so
there is demand for for something
different than you know these uh kind of
um Google world garden where you know
data is all in one place and uh you know
to find the the blue links you have to
kind of move between different uh
objects rotating around you. So I I
think that the demand is there for also
a different experience. So what I
envision in the future is that uh it's
going to be additive. So we're going to
have you know multiple sources but uh
the data that we own is what uh in the
end it's going to kind of make the
difference of of the brand visibility
because it's it's hard for for you know
any publisher or or company to own the
way in which the information is
represented by an an AI system. what we
can do is like kind of you know control
the data that we're feeding these AI
with. That's that's that remains for me
you know kind of the core objective of
of of doing SEO and marketing
>> which maybe maybe we can kind of come to
a last little chunk which is how do the
I mean you're you're saying build an
internal knowledge graph and feed the
machines. How do the machines learn? I
mean from a um a retrieval information
retrieval perspective Dor starting from
there how do these machines how is
Google learning? How is it building its
knowledge graph?
>> Well, presumably it's just now it's just
continued transfer learning as well, you
know, uh very much like and andy's not
really shown us this this new multimodal
thing that he was uh he shared the other
day on Twitter. But uh but ultimately
now the more the more uh machine
learning will be is able to break down
tasks and add and do more across small
task and not have to keep starting again
with the learning the more things like
data is gifted by the likes of Microsoft
through the the likes of the MS Marco
community and the click query data and
Google for instance gifting natural
questions and the more people feed in
questions ire people also ask etc.
That's all just gonna that's all just
self-arning feed forward but small
teacher student and teacher
relationships are going on on all the
time in machine learning as well now. So
for me it's all it's all just everything
is just piling forward into a whole like
feed forward transfer learning. So just
keep growing and growing,
>> right?
>> And obviously they have like the
standard
inverted indexes anyway and now
vector-based indexes and and just a huge
growing comm growing community for
instance as well. Python is the most
used language growing language in the in
the world now and that's obviously one
of the foundations of machine learning
natural language processing. So it's all
kind of headed in the hockey stick
learning and growth period I would say.
>> I don't know. Would you agree anybody on
that?
>> No no that totally. I mean I think that
the other big change is that at the
moment we still have um sort of two
areas you know the the knowledge graph
and reasoning side of of AI and then the
deep learning on the other side. that
this is uh finally converging and and
and models will be able to to reason on
on on on the data that they they have
acquired which is currently the problem
because of course uh a lot of these
models are not grounded and so the
knowledge graph it's kind of providing
guidance to the to the deep learning
algorithm but um you know with evolution
of architecture like Google pathways the
way forward is that these uh these these
language models are in general this this
uh um transformer based model are going
to be able to assess if if a fact is
true or not. So embedding in a way the
knowledge graph into into themselves
which is what is missing at the moment.
And this is also why it gets so
difficult for you know managing the
different modalities because we we had
uh for for many years different models
for different media. But now finally
we're kind of converging and we can have
in the same vector space you know the
data coming from from the audio clip and
the data coming from a video clip and
it's it's the same vector space that
that can be can be analyzed. So I think
that the evolution is really you know
the knowledge graph to be embedded into
into this uh transfer learning uh uh
procedure and and and the new way in
which neural networks are going to be
designed seems to go in that direction.
Well, and bring up something
controversial um but I think important
and that is I wonder how much other type
of learning um is happening on what I
assume exists in the Google verse which
is um kind of like a personspecific
knowledge graph because we've been
talking about this from the searcher
perspective but um what about the the
knowledge that Google is gaining and
machine learning about you and me and
cohorts and applying what they know
about you and me to cohorts and vice
versa to do a good job using this
knowledge graph to
um understand what would be useful to
surface to individual people or cohorts
um and what they have in common because
I don't think that's the same
necessarily um it's probably not using
linguistic
um modeling, but other kinds of
modeling. And so I think I think that's
also interesting is that they're using
different kinds of modeling for to solve
different kinds of problems um that all
feed into this end product. Do you guys
agree that that's happening or is that
just a conspiracy theory on my part?
>> I think without it we couldn't have
Google discover.
>> Yeah, exactly. It's 100% happening. I
don't even think that it's not even a
secret. I mean, you've got the likes of
Christian Balog who who who writes on
entity oriented search who's now uh he's
he's just joined Google actually as a as
a research professor. Uh he's still a
professor in Stavinger, but he's joined
Google. He's the author of entity
oriented search. He does a lot of talks
about personal knowledge graphs. Yeah.
personal I mean the minute you program
your Google home you can say to it uh
you can tell it who your husband is you
can tell it the names of your dogs your
cats you can tell it the name of your
mom so that you can then say hey call
mom type thing so that is that's a
personal knowledge graph that that's the
connections that you have with the
people around you obviously coupled with
your search history you opt into that
you have to opt into Google discover
So you're saying to them, help me find
what I need. Yeah. So yeah, that's it's
it's and definitely there will be some
cohort stuff going on. Otherwise, flock
the federated learning of cohorts thing
wouldn't be such a big deal. So yeah,
it's it's not even a it's not even a
conspiracy.
>> It's Yeah, definitely a fact, not a
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You're definitely not
going mad, Cindy. No, no, no. We we'll
let you know. But of course, it's not
something that it's it's been uh
probably
spoken aloud too much because there's uh
of course a lot of concern when when it
gets to to private personal data and we
know that the regulation is still uh
possibly not clear enough. uh in Europe
it's definitely better than uh than in
the US but it's still uh you know
challenging to understand you know where
we should draw the line and where the
data should be processed locally and
where it can be sent back to the cloud.
I mean we we we we read a lot of the
scandals for you know Alexa or or Google
Home capturing voices and using it for
training systems centrally. It's a very
blurry and and complicated area, but
definitely that's the only way that uh
you know Google can create a a system
like discover otherwise there's no it
wouldn't work.
>> It's a bit like it's a bit like
switching on Spotify or Netflix
99% recommendation for Dawn is such and
such a film that would not be possible
without a personal knowledge graph of
some type you know or some sort of
history mapped together. uh and that is
you know that I think is the way
forward. It's it's it's ultimately just
recommended systems isn't it?
>> Yeah.
>> Well know this but do you think most
people realize this?
>> No because as I said it's not a topic
that can be clearly spoken out uh for
for many of these companies it's a it's
regulation is not also uniform across
the globe. So I can say something in
Europe and and mention GDPR but then for
you GDPR is not a thing and and so it's
it's it's no it's definitely in general
personal knowledge graph are a frontier
and here at connected data there are
going to be interesting talk about
personal knowledge graph because besides
the fact that can be used by corporation
like Google and Spotify they can also be
used by you know any human being for
organizing you know whatever whatever
working activities you have or documents
you have uh you know on your computer
But yeah, definitely it's a gray area.
>> Well, I I think kind of if you if you
talk about this to to most people, they
would think of browsing history or
activity history, which seems like this
kind of linear list that's reasonably
harmless. If you say to somebody
actually it's not, it's a knowledge
graph, a personal knowledge graph, then
it gets scary. So kind of
>> but also
>> when you ask the data here in Europe and
and you can ask data, then you get
linear data, right?
I was going to say I don't I don't think
search history is considered part of
that personal knowledge graph as such.
That for me is almost like that's almost
like the equivalent of text that fills
in the gaps between the entities. So the
entities in the personal knowledge graph
are me, my dogs, my mom, my sister, my
husband, my house, etc. And for me the
brosing history is almost like that's
the that's like the natural language
part of it that fills in the gaps. So we
all have to work together almost if you
like.
>> Sure. But you were talking about
Spotify. I mean Spotify basically it's
browsing history building it up into
your preferences.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Fair enough. Yeah. Yeah. But
well then recommend I don't know maybe
I'm talking nonsense but for me a
personal knowledge graph is based on
entities. Yeah.
>> Right. I mean from from but it it could
also be based on topicality because I
with the Spotify example if if I listen
to loads of country and western music it
will just it will see that kind of
topicality in my tastes and keep
throwing that at me.
>> Yeah, good point. The artist maybe the
entities in that regard then are the
songs the uh artists and the
>> Yeah, etc. Yeah. The genres. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So that is a personal knowledge graph in
that regard. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I mean I mean from the music
perspective, I mean I've been building
out my musical, excuse me, but like from
my songs and my albums and the
characters and the screenshot I showed
earlier on is is actually just a
knowledge graph of songs to albums that
are linked to me because I was the
performer.
>> Yeah. And I suppose in that regard then
the search history is going to be again
topics
>> could be mapped to topics and
>> interest. Yeah. Interest topics etc.
Cohort
>> the topic layer. Sorry. Go ahead, Cindy.
>> Personal knowledge graph um could be
used really well to help with
disambiguation. So, for instance, if I'm
a Google knows that I'm a 10-year-old
kid and I search for Michelangelo,
um it's going to hope well um probably
show the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle uh
instead of the artist um based on what
it knows about me and what it knows
about people like me.
>> Yeah, I would say so. Yeah, 100%.
Yeah. Again, that's a funny one as a I
think that's just a really bad example
of a 10-year-old kid because obviously,
you know, it's like, yeah, it's a funny
one to pick. It's a funny one to use and
and expand upon just because of the age
thing is such a big deal as well, isn't
it? You know, it's whether they would I
mean, you can't you can't even opt into
Google at 10 years old. That's the
>> Right. Well, and you would hope that
maybe they're doing a school report and
not writing about
>> Exactly. Yeah. But no, exact. Yeah,
definitely. I would I would agree with
that. It's probability determination of
what did that user mean?
>> It's going to make it's like it's going
to make a huge difference.
>> Well, in in in that perspective, the the
personal knowledge graph helps with
understanding intent and the general
knowledge graph helps with providing the
correct solution that matches to that
intent.
>> I think it just all fits together. It's
just all about probability determination
and disamiguation. That's that's that's
what search is about and that's what
knowledge B. That's everything is about
just dismbiguation, isn't it?
>> Right. And Google's learning faster and
faster and it's uh exponential and it's
deeply scary for some people and
incredibly interesting for others. And
there you go. So, anything else we want
to talk about? We've got kind of another
five five or 10 minutes. If there's any
kind of closing points that I've
completely missed out on Cindy,
apparently I have.
>> It was
>> Sorry, just go ahead, Don.
>> I was just going to say I wanted to
point out, you know, you mentioned the
clarifying questions thing, Cindy. That
is that is massively going to be a huge
thing with voice because voice obviously
has this issue with uh well, I'm talking
about Google Home and voice and mobile
combined. uh the the issue with
precision is really poor of of actually
getting you the right result. So there's
a few including Bing as well and
Microsoft that have been doing work on
clarifying questions because what they
found is that if you can narrow down the
field just a bit by clarifying with a
few you know like coming back and saying
did you mean this do you want to see
Jason Barard's songs because under the
because of unpecified queries the the
precision massively increases then on
meeting the information need that is
definitely going to be bigger and bigger
I suspect in home voice and any any
spoken interaction.
>> Yep. Totally agree. Well, and what I was
going to say, Jason, is I think that
there is a common sense um kind of
strategy that comes out of this concept
of of everything potentially needing
disambiguation or disambiguation being
so key uh to understanding and you know
the clarifying questions. And that is if
you're starting something brand new um
and you want to have an easy time uh
surfacing in a search result of any kind
whether it's with a knowledge graph or
with voice or or what have you. Um the
less disambiguation needed the better.
So, for instance, um it would not be a
good idea um now to start a band called
Bread, which does exist, but like um it
used to be that if you searched Google
for bread, you would get did you mean
the food or the band? They've realized
that most people mean the food, so they
don't even ask anymore. Um and that's um
disappointing if you're the band. Um, so
creating uh new names that are not
otherwise taken or not otherwise
confusing or needing disambiguation. If
you're just starting in something, let's
say you're just starting in an industry
and you know that your name is John uh
something uh perhaps uh make your name
or make your uh personal brand under a
variation that's more recognizable and
less competitive. or if you're starting
a company, don't or a band, don't call
it bread or don't call it something
that's going to need disambiguation. And
I'll tell you that this is one of the
reasons that we have such creative names
for some of our tools is um I wanted to
be able to race to the top when people
search for serpator
um because that's a word that didn't
exist. So there's no competition. Um, so
I think that's just an interesting and
easy kind of strategy takeaway from this
is don't need disambiguation if you can.
>> Right. Yeah. No 100%. I mean a lot of
companies are scared of that but um and
people as well but that idea of of
saying especially with a unique name I
can create the meaning of that name for
my audience at the same time as making
it much easier for me to get stuff of
Google. But I think a lot of companies
are afraid of that. And that tradition
in SEO at least of calling your company
by what it does because it helped in
ranking 10 years ago is still stuck in a
lot of people's brains unfortunately.
>> Andy, have you got any incredible
insights to add before we wrap all this
up?
>> Uh, no. I think I think we we went
through a lot. I mean, I'm pretty happy.
I want to just uh you know, I took notes
uh and uh and then I'm I'm going to try
to summarize it.
>> Me, too. I've got page and pages of
scribbles that I won't be able to read.
>> We went through a lot. I mean we we we
we saw basically how you know search is
getting you know more conversational you
know you know the knowledge graph is
being fed by you know queries uh
popularity conversation and uh you know
the importance of uh of the question and
answer pairs in in kind of driving the
experience around these entities. how
indeed uh we need new tools for uh you
know tracking search results because the
tools that we have at the moment don't
have you know enough data for us to
understand exactly how visible we are
and so that's that's also another
interesting point that I got I mean we
went through a lot we we we saw also how
everything is becoming multimodel and so
we should become multimodel too meaning
that we should start to look at entities
in terms of you know different
modalities and different content pieces
and kind of detach from, you know, the
traditional way of looking at results.
>> So, that I think that was an incredibly
good kind of summary of what we all
talked about. I I don't think anybody
could have done better. I certainly
couldn't. Um, should we just say
goodbye? And I'd like to say thank you
to the three of you because I really
enjoyed that.
>> Cool. Well, thanks to everybody.
>> Thank you so much, Cindy. Thank you so
much, Dawn. Thank you, Andy. And thank
you to the audience for watching. And
thank you for connected data for
organizing this. That was one of the
most phenomenally interesting
conversations I've had in many, many,
many a moon. Thanks a lot everybody.
Bye-bye.
>> Bye. Bye. Bye.